Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
When looking for illustrations for a presentation,
most of the time, I quickly find an appropriate
photo on the internet, however, many of these
photos are really low resolution.
This often creates a weird situation where
I have think, okay, do I use the splotchier,
lower-resolution image that gets the point
across, or take a high-resolution, crisp image
that is less educational?
In case you are wondering, I encounter this
problem for almost every single video I make
for this channel.
As you can surely tell, I am waiting for the
day when super resolution becomes mainstream.
Super resolution means that we have a low
resolution image that lacks details, and we
feed it to a computer program, which hallucinates
all the details onto it, creating a crisp,
high-resolution image.
This way, I could take my highly relevant,
but blurry image, improve it, and use it in
my videos.
As adding details to images clearly requires
a deep understanding of what is shown in these
images, our seasoned Fellow Scholars immediately
know that learning-based algorithms will be
ideal for this task.
While we are looking at some amazing results
with this new technique, let's talk about
the two key differences that this method introduces:
One, it takes a fully progressive approach,
which means that we don't immediately produce
the highest resolution output we are looking
for, but slowly leapfrog our way through intermediate
steps, each of which is only slightly higher
resolution than the input.
This means that the final output is produced
over several steps, where each problem is
only a tiny bit harder than the previous one.
This is often referred to as curriculum learning
and it not only increases the quality of the
solution, but is also easier to train as solving
each intermediate step is only a little harder
than the previous one.
It is a bit like how students learn in school:
first, the students are shown some easy introductory
tasks to get a grasp of a problem, and slowly
work their way towards mastering a field by
solving problems that gradually increase in
difficulty.
Two, now, we can start playing with the thought
of using a generative adversarial network.
We talk a lot about this architecture in this
series, at this time I will only note that
training these is fraught with difficulties,
so every bit of help we can get is more than
welcome, so the role of curriculum learning
is to help easing this process.
Note that this research field is well-explored,
and has a remarkable number of papers, so
I was expecting a lot of comparisons against
competing techniques.
And when looking at the paper and the supplementary
materials, boy, did I get it!
Make sure to have a look at the paper, it
contains a very exhaustive validation section,
which reveals that if we measure the error
of the solution in terms of human perception,
it is only slightly lower quality than the
best technique, however, this one is five
times quicker, offering a really nice balance
between quality and performance.
So, what about the actual numbers for the
execution time?
For instance, upsampling an image to increase
its resolution to twice its original size
takes less than a second, and we can go to
up to even eight times the original resolution,
which also only takes four and a half seconds.
The quality and the execution times indicate
that we are again, one step closer to mainstream
super resolution.
What a time to be alive!
The source code of this project is also available.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!